we have a periodic function depicted
here what I want you to do is think
about what the midline of this function
is the midline is a line a horizontal
line where half of the function is above
it and half of the function is below it
then I want you to think about the
amplitude how far does this function
vary from that midline either how far
above does it go or how far does it go
below and it should be the same amount
because the midline should be between
the highest and the lowest point and
then finally think about what the period
of this function is how far how long do
you have to how much do you have to have
a change in X to get to the same point
in the cycle of this periodic function
so I encourage you to pause the video
now and think about those questions so
let's tackle the midline first so one
way to think about it is well how high
does this function go well the highest Y
value for this function we see is 4 it
keeps hitting 4 and a fairly regular
basis and we'll talk about how regular
that is when we talk about the period
and what's the lowest value that this
function gets to well it gets to y
equals negative 2
so what's halfway between 4 and negative
2 well you could eyeball it or you could
count or you could literally just take
the average between 4 and negative 2 so
4 so we could the midline is going to be
the horizontal line y is equal to 4 plus
negative 2 over 2 just literally the
mean the arithmetic mean between 4 and
negative 2 the average of 4 and negative
2 which is just going to be equal to 1
so the line y equals 1 is the midline so
that's the midline right over here and
you see that you see that it's kind of
cutting the function in it's where you
have half of the function is above it
and half of the function is below it so
that's the midline mid line now let's
think about the amplitude well the
amplitude is how much this function
varies from the midline either above the
midline or below the midline and the
middle ends in the middle so it's going
to be the same amount whether you go
above or below
so if you one way to say it is well at
this maximum point right over here how
far above the midline is this how far
above the midline is this is this well
to get from one to four you have to go
you're three above the midline or
another way of thinking about this
maximum point is y equals four minus y
equals one well you had a you your Y can
go as much as three above the midline or
you could say your Y value could be as
much as three below the midline that's
this point right over here one minus
three is negative one so your amplitude
right over here is equal to three you
can vary as much as three either above
the midline or below the midline
finally the period and when I think
about the period I try to look for a a
relatively convenient spot on the curve
and I I'm calling this a convenient spot
because it's at a nice when X is at
negative two Y is at one it's at a nice
integer value and so what I want to do
is keep traveling along this curve until
I get to the same y value but not just
the same value Y value but the Y value I
get the same y value and I'm also
traveling in the same direction so for
example let's travel along this curve so
essentially our X is increasing our X
keeps increasing now you might say hey
have I completed a cycle here because
once again Y is equal to one you haven't
completed a cycle here because notice
over here where our Y is increasing as x
increases well here our Y is decreasing
as x increases our slope is positive
here our slope is negative here so this
isn't the same point on the cycle we
need to get to the point where Y once
again equals one or we could say
especially in this case we're at the
midline again but our slope is
increasing so let's just keep going
let's just keep going so that gets us to
right over there so notice now we have
completed one cycle so this the change
in X needed to complete one cycle that
is your that is your period so to go
from negative 2 to 0 your period is 2 so
your period here is 2 and you could do
it again so we're at that point
let's see we want to get back to a point
where we're at the midline and it you
know I just happen to start right over
here at the midline I could have started
really at any point you want to get to
the same point but also where the slope
is the same we're at the same point in
the cycle once again so I could go so if
I travel one I'm at the midline again
but I'm now going down so I have to go
further now I am back at that same point
in the cycle I'm at y equals 1 and the
slope is positive and notice I traveled
my change in X my change in X was the
length of the period it was 2